foreign
my best friend and her family were in a
severe car accident and it looked like
they weren't going to survive their
whole family survived and I find myself
really angry and jealous that their
family is intact and mine is not
[Music]
what is going on this is John with Dr
John Maloney show
talk to real people about real things
going on in their life struggles people
are trying to figure out what to do next
when it comes to their mental health or
their marriage to their parenting
probably pet ownership I'm also a closet
expert in parent owners I'm not at all
not even a little bit I got some
chickens and I'm not even good at that
but hey if you want to be on the show to
talk about your mental health your
marriage whatever's going on give me a
buzz at
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask
and hey it is such a gift if you will
take to me to the team but way more
importantly than us
um if you will take a second to like or
subscribe to this show it kicks that up
in the algorithms for your friends and
your neighbors if you're thinking the
world's gone crazy why is everybody
if you will like And subscribe the show
it puts up in into the algorithms and it
kicks it into more people's feed and
they'll click on it and then they will
we'll all be able to start talking the
same language of healing and not being
terrible parents and loving our kids
better and all those things we can do
together
so like subscribe do all the clicks and
the whatever send this show to people
that you know and
um let's go out to New York City to
enjoy and talk to you Diane what's up
Diane
hello thank you for taking my call of
course doing okay
okay I'm nervous I'm sorry oh don't be
nervous I'm not good at this you know
you know that so we're good we're good
what's up okay all righty so um I'm been
married uh almost 44 years been with my
husband for 45 we got married very young
44.
44 years in August it will be you are
straight gangster congratulations not
really
well it hasn't happened pretty
soon you're still still walking still
walking all right so what's up
well we're actually headed for divorce
because God deloney shut your mouth hey
I do that all the time I get all excited
about something and I cut somebody off
and then you say oh well now we're
getting divorced so sorry about that I'm
here celebrating you
yeah yeah that's that's just
anyways you know we've had our troubles
through the years but um
increasingly my husband's always been a
prepper we have a Y2K room if that tells
you anything and so um he's always been
kind of in that most
which has actually come in handy
sometimes because we you know we have
extra food and stuff when you run out of
something but um
but in the last like probably five years
and more so in the last two years he's
just
um on his iPad following conspiracy
series he's still working but he's
um you know he's just very I'd say
brainwashed to tell you the truth it's
quite bad and uh he's done stuff he's
handled our money our whole life which
I realized that probably wasn't very
wise I mean I've worked two most of our
marriage but I was the person that
handed my paycheck over and I get a
check per month and I have some credit
card use and I just didn't question
because
I believed he was putting our money in
savings and you know IRAs and I think he
used to be more conventional but now I
found out that he's put it all in gold
and silver and cryptocurrency and he
literally thinks the banks are crashing
and
um yeah just a lot of things he thinks
you know so are y'all getting divorced
is that happening
well what happened was I just so what
happened
you know the reason it came to that is I
just I was just we were just getting
more and more separate and you know he
was just watching these news things and
he kept saying you know anybody that got
a kova shot is going to die you know and
just I mean just these really bizarre
sure bizarre hold on answer my question
Dane are y'all getting divorced because
it's gonna it's gonna impact how I
answer this question
I don't know
for sure that's when I wrote a letter he
kind of I wrote him a letter say I'm
just and I've been watching you and Dave
Ramsey probably for the last six months
and so I decided to take a leap and just
say you know I'm really afraid about
what's going on we seem like more
distance and I don't know what's going
on with our finances I'm worried about
things you're doing it scares me
and either we need to talk about this
and get counseling or I don't know if we
need to separate or get a divorce but I
don't want to live prepping for the end
of the world and not enjoying life
anymore you know not for you Diane good
for you what was his response
well I said you know don't
talk to me when you're ready
um so he came the next night home from
work and
he didn't have anything written down but
instead of talking about that he brought
up
all the things I did in my past that
hurt our marriage you know and uh
and he said you're right we're not happy
we should just
split and I want we have a very complex
we have three properties you know a
business yada yada
he told me what he wanted and that he
was doing this this and this and this
and I mean I was really quite honestly
shocked and then I started asking him
well I need the finances you know I mean
literally we spent eight hours one day
unscrewing walls because there's gold
hidden in walls of all our properties
wow and it took us that long to go so I
mean I think I have piles of silver
somewhere you know and some in the walls
but
um here's what needs to happen ASAP okay
let me just
um he doesn't want attorneys involved
and I don't that ship has sailed or I
have I have four adult dollar you know
it's just very complicated it is yeah
I'm sorry none of this is complicated
okay
yeah you have a husband who's losing
touch in front of you with reality
yes and
um
he is it has left the iPad
um brain relationship where it's just
somebody getting transfixed by a screen
and now he is taking
increasingly erratic
um unsafe behaviors when I say unsafe
I'm not being dramatic here he is
putting you in exceptional Financial
Risk
yeah if something happens to him you are
sunk
because crypto and gold and silver are
three of the stupidest Investments you
can make
and
have people made money on crypto of
course
way more people lost
everything well he already admitted that
he lost a lot right and I don't know
what because he won't show me that and I
don't even understand that nor does he
understands
here's what he gets
he gets 48 hours to come clean with
where the finances are and where what is
and what's been spent and what the debt
ratios are and all that stuff I would
um
go to the credit bureaus and pull your
credit reports Google it because there's
a Kelly can you find that there's one
site where you can pull your credit
report from all three
because you need to know what has been
leveraged against you
what go ahead I did get a little bit of
information when this happened I did say
I need all these my all our financials
within a week and for what I know he did
produce that
I mean we do he put all our IRAs and I
don't even know how he moved mine to
like a gold Trust Company and most of
the stuff those he's just taken out or
he's lost by making bad decisions
um but listen but listen but listen okay
okay it's okay it's okay you've got a
person who's
not rational
who is doing things behind your back
yeah who is investing in things losing
tons of money
putting your family at risk
And yet when you say give me everything
you just trust everything you put in
front of you
I would not do that given the track
record here
okay and given the fact that he walked
in after you said here's what I need for
a relationship to stay whole and he came
in and said ah I'm out and here's what I
need here's what I'm gonna take
so you've heard me say Steve it is yeah
it's morning then I mean because it's
just
it's just horrific trying to sort it
through and just
the trauma of it all and just the
sadness of it all too because I mean I
feel like I'm talking to you strangers
it's heartbreaking he wrote a note today
saying I'd like to work it out
but so I'm going to come up with a list
of all the things we have to do
immediately so I was going to take that
approach right so I mean I don't know if
it I don't know if I can get him out of
this brainwashed thinking because I
don't
well I don't think I don't think there
is there can be but uh Kelly what did
you say that was
annualcreditreport.com okay so before
the day is over both of you have pulled
up an annualcreditreport.com
that tells you what you owe
any hidden debts that he has on that he
has piled up on his side any debts he's
taken out in your name with your social
security card number on your side it
lets you know what you owe
yeah then he's already given you an
account of an accounting of all the IRAs
that he's moved into gold
all of those go back
and I want you to call a smartvester pro
and those are certified I can only move
well I don't know what you don't even
know if anything is
anything but I mean I've been married 44
years yes but what he said was I want to
work it out
and so your terms of here's how what
working it out means is this
I need to know what this family owes you
and me combined I need to know where
every penny is I need to know every
penny you've lost
number four I'm cutting the internet off
to this house for 60 days
no internet access in this home
just you and me
number five we're going to marriage
counseling
and if you say no to any of these things
you are opting out of staying in this
marriage
because Diane I'm telling you right now
I've sat with too many widows who just
lost their husband who look at me with
this it's it's a very unique look
and they say something along the lines
of what do I do now because they don't
know where the money is they don't know
where the titles are they don't know
what's insured what's not insured they
don't know if their husband had wives
that they didn't know they don't know
anything
you are so exposed right now
and yeah that's why I'm I'm you can hear
it in my voice that's why I'm so adamant
the only way you get control back on
your life is if you grab it with both
hands and I would not ask a person who
is detaching from reality right before
your eyes to be The Driver of building
your new life
you've got to take the reins and you
haven't had to do that for 44 years you
got to start now
yeah and I know that's terrifying I know
I have started and I do have a lot of
the information but I just don't know I
do have a lot of all the account numbers
I know the accountings of things I've
been able to get stuff I've gotten keys
I mean we have internet everywhere
though he can go anywhere we have
several properties that have it you know
I mean we have a lot of assets what I do
know is our houses all our properties
are free and clear okay that's awesome
so it didn't that you know that you know
of
I know of you know yes I don't know
I don't know if he took a HELOC out
against one of those properties and
bought well
three hundred thousand dollars for the
crypto
he did pay back whatever he took out he
didn't do that I
because I saw I've been opening the mail
and uh because it's all in his name and
some he gets shipped somewhere else I
don't know but uh Diane do you trust me
that when I'm telling you that you are
you are so exposed right now
he's somebody have known since I was 17
and
I'm a
I I feel like I'm
betraying him too when I
do these things you know I don't want to
get him in trouble
I don't know
I understand what you're saying I know
it is important let's listen you you're
right to have your heart broken
and you're right to miss your friend
and you're right to miss the main that
you built a life with
I mean if you include 44 years of
marriage plus knowing him you've known
him for half a century
I know right and so I I'm not telling
you to not be heartbroken and be so sad
that you're watching the person you
spent the majority of your life with
just
fall through your hands like sand right
through your fingertips I get that yeah
and
there's a reality that it's actually
happening so you have to grieve this
this is hard and scary and my my deepest
prayer is that he circles up and goes oh
she's serious
um I I don't like living like this
either I don't know anybody in that
space in that mind frame that likes
being there
and sometimes
they get lost to it but other times they
just need someone who loves them to flip
a light switch on and say whoa
you're about to lose everything all of
your money all the homes your wife your
daughters
because you are so down a rabbit hole of
Crazy Stupid news conspiracies and
everybody listening yes some of these
conspiracies end up being true what are
you gonna do about it
nothing
so
pulling are all the banks gonna fail no
they're not
they're not and if they are let's say
they do if they do having gold stash in
your walls will not protect you from
what comes next
because your neighbors will come after
you for your water you're talking about
an apocalyptic movie you're not talking
about oh it's gonna pull the gold out so
we can buy cars and get to work on time
that will be over
so stop with
stop with the conspiracy nonsense
because you can listen to Diane this is
what's left in the wake
scared
spouses
scared kids
Diana is heartbreaking heartbreaking
heartbreaking heartbreaking I totally
get it I want you to stay on the line
I'm gonna send you a copy of own your
past change your future here's our book
here's the book is about dealing with
the scary stuff in the past and then
answering that scary question what are
we going to do now because you and your
husband are gonna have to build a new
relationship
or you're gonna have to build a new life
and all told you have to take
responsibility for what happens in your
life even though this guy has been
walking alongside you ride or die for 50
years that appears to have changed
that means you gotta change and it's
gonna be heartbreaking angry crying rage
all those things are right
but you got to take control take control
also you know what Diane stay on the
line I'm gonna send you
um Financial Peace University for a year
I work for Ramsey solutions for Dave
Ramsey and his Flagship product
Financial Peace University we'll walk
you and your husband through how to deal
with money
in a non-insane way
okay so hang on the line I'm gonna send
you both of those things that's on me
it's for free and I want you and your
husband to just say as a condition of us
staying together I want you to watch
these videos with me
okay Dave Ramsey's helped millions and
millions and millions and millions of
people become Millionaires and get out
of debt and take care of their family
Legacy through common sense not through
some internet IG down a YouTube rabbit
hole hack
love you Diane and I'm so sorry you're
going through this
so sorry we'll be right back
[Music]
hey good folks Dr John deloney here look
you made it halfway through the year
congratulations and maybe you started
this year being a little bit more
intentional about mindfulness and then
the culture convinced you that you gotta
run harder snap into a Slim Jim and you
find yourself back on social media
watching nonsense influencers sharing
their life hacks for doing more and more
and more listen my friends
don't sacrifice sleep at the altar of
productivity hustling is well and good
working hard accomplishing things is
great but burnout is very real and
burnout is when your body just says I'm
out
and as a society we are exhausted and
when you're running on empty you got to
remember to recharge your body sleep is
the number one way to recharge your
physical and mental health and for me
getting great sleep starts with a great
mattress and that's why I love dream
cloud and right now dream Cloud
mattresses are running an awesome offer
exclusively for our listeners 40 off all
mattresses plus an additional fifty
dollars in savings
time to start prioritizing your sleep go
to dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo
code John deloney that's
dreamcloudsleep.com with code John
deloney
all right we are back let's go to Jeff
in Orlando what's up Jeff
yes what's up man
not not you just saving the world dude
that's probably oh I didn't tell the
truth I'm not saying I'm not saving the
world I'm uh podcasting what's up man
I'm not much so
um we talk about in um your book on your
past on your future all about the
loneliness and everything
how do you as someone that is
mostly working solo and you know Flying
Solo in day to day how do you make the
space to like build those relationships
and that you know authentic stuff and
not just have like a gazillion people oh
hey I know a guy
and you know actually have those like
real like real you know real friendships
real authentic stuff dude that's a great
question man thank you for asking that
question
um so I'm taking that you were you have
a solo job what do you do for a living
I work in the uh like Landscaping green
industry okay so you're you're you got
headphones on and you're cutting grass
and and weed eating all day long huh
yes pressure washing sweeping blowing
the whole thing right
yeah and unless I stop at like a gas
station or a Chick-fil-A or somewhere to
you know use the bathroom or
I forgot to pack lunch or something like
that I usually don't
interact with anybody okay and then are
you married or do you do you live alone
I live alone okay
So reading that book
um and on your past change of future
there's a whole chapter about loneliness
reading that book
was probably unsettling to say the least
is that right
yeah because it's like yeah there's a
lot of people I know there's not a lot
of people that
oh hey I you know
really you know I need someone to drive
me to the hospital at three o'clock in
the morning or anything like that
there's
no one sells that contact list
can I tell you how impressed I am with
you
to have the courage to say that out loud
because that's scary to say or isn't it
yeah yeah dude I
um I'm proud of you for saying that now
the next step is you gotta go do
something about it right so
I think the first part of this shift and
change starts with an identity change a
shift in who I am
because right now you are a guy that
freaking gets it done
you work hard you're disciplined you
knock your lights out you do all the
stuff you're crushing it at work you're
doing it
and what I want you to do is to expand
that identity
and you are somebody
that is a great friend and has great
friends that's who you are
and it's a weird it's weird math and so
when I say weird math
it never would have occurred to me in a
million years that I would rather hang
out with my seven-year-old daughter than
some of my knucklehood knuckleheaded
friends from back in in when I was a kid
and my seven-year-old daughter cost me
all my money and takes up a lot of time
and doesn't always sleep through the
night
and you would think those things stacked
up against wanting to be around them
wouldn't work right because if you have
a friend that took all your money and
didn't want to be around and didn't
sleep all that you wouldn't want to hang
out with them
so that when I tell you the math doesn't
work like on parenting
I want to tell you the math doesn't work
on friendship either I don't understand
it
but here's what I know if you will
invest and work really hard as hard as
you do on your landscape stuff if you
will work that hard to get a couple of
guy friends in your life to start
hanging out to have a group of guys and
I'll walk you through a few few ideas I
have
if you will do that you will see
exponential growth in your business also
you'll see exponential return on your
health also unless you all get together
and do stupid stuff
so you might think I don't have time for
this I don't have time for that I don't
know how it works or why it works but
the invested time in human relationships
and friendships always comes back
exponentially in your work okay
yeah so you're now a guy who has friends
and who is a great friend
sometimes for me that means
I call somebody on the way home from
work I start thinking about who I'm
going to call on the way to the parking
lot when I'm walking out and we just
chat on the phone could be people from
all over the United States
from childhood from I was a little kid
to just a few years ago but I'll call
somebody on the way home just to check
in and chat and see how things are going
another one is
you can build time into gathering places
because a Cornerstone of having friends
is shared experiences so it might be the
gym it might be the softball league it
might be playing chess start teaching
guys at your local church like hey I'm
doing a
how to fix your mower how to do pressure
washing class after church if y'all want
to come hang another thing might be is
once a week you dedicate one half of a
Saturday to going around and mowing
lawns for people who don't have any
money and you invite some guys from you
know your church or from wherever to
come with you
and what you're doing is you're doing
shared experiences and then everybody
pitches in and you'll get pizza or
you'll go grab lunch when it's all over
um here's all I can say is this you have
to be hyper extra intentional about it
so when I tell you that I know you've
already thought of some of those things
what is your pushback like it does it
sound stupid or Pie in the Sky when I
say those things
well it's probably just the you know
the maybe I'll I almost want to say the
laziness of going
I don't even know if that's the right
word but go in the wall you know get
home I want you know crack a cold drink
and turn on the TV and you know pop and
you know and The Lazy Boy and go up some
steaks and call it a day
and it's called I can't think of two
things as a grown man I would rather be
I would I would want to be called less
than a boy and lazy
and that's the name of most of our
prized possessions
that that glorious recliner
and so yes there is a lazy I don't say
laziness there is an intentionality
component you're gonna have to choose a
different kind of life it's going to be
uncomfortable for a while
my promises my promise is if you get two
or three guys that are coming over
having steaks with you a couple times a
week and they're bringing some of the
steaks and then one of them shows up
with catfish and one of them shows up
with venison whatever
and y'all are laughing and carrying on
and playing cards instead of
just watching TV
you will find a richness in your life
that you didn't know existed
I my my deeper question is
have you made it this far have you
always just kind of been a do it do it
on your own kind of guy or is this a
recent recent
um shift in your life
probably a little bit of both
I had a lot of friends growing up like I
knew you know hung out and like and it
wasn't like a jock I wasn't exactly a
you know like chess team or you know
choir or you know I wasn't particularly
one
like you know particular group that had
people that I knew and various different
things and would hang out with and do
stuff but it was all it was probably
always like at least the feeling of oh
on the you know kind of like the wall
you know the Wallflower of on the
outside looking end
um can I ask you a hard question Jeff
sure
why don't you think you're worth having
friends
because I'd be willing to I'd be willing
to bet you money that's the most people
that you think you were just being a
Wallflower would count you as one of
their buddies
or to put it another way
I bet you a couple of those guys from
high school that you hung out with would
have called you if they gotten a mess
but yeah I know I've had a few people
that have called me because like they're
having marriage problems or they need
some extra work or you know that kind of
stuff but it's you know it's like
sometimes I guess sometimes it's the
quiet ones that you watch out for
because those you know now having you
know done a few various other jobs
it's like first you know you know or
people that I know that are in I've got
some people I know that like First
Responders and stuff and they it always
seems like they say
if white one says once No One Ever Knows
that stuff happens
and it's like well you know not and I'm
not saying anything but on that it's
just like well
I'm always I always seem to find it
easier to be the one that people always
call
and it's hard to build the relationships
to actually say hey let's go do
pizza or let's you know throw some
steaks on the grill because you think
that they don't want to be around you
or that you don't want to bother anybody
Jeff you're you're not a bother
you have to you have to look inside
internally and believe that people are
going to be blessed by having you on
their life not the other way around
nobody's life is better when Jeff is not
in it that's not true
people's life is better you make their
life better by your the job you do
you know what you give families
when you go mow their lawn and clean it
up
you know what you give them you give
them time with their families the single
most precious resource that's ever been
created in the history of the world
you give an exhausted mother and a
completely fried father
time with their family
like you're a gift man
and you also get to talk to all kinds of
wackadoo people every day
when you take money when you do their
yards with their requests and all that
kind of stuff you have a lot to offer
man
and it breaks my heart that you think
you don't
you believe me when I tell you you do
yeah okay
then I want you to quit holding out on
the world and hiding Jeff from
here's what here's what I want you I
want you to pretend and or uh practice
make it a priority put it once or twice
on the count once twice a week on your
calendar I'm gonna call a couple of
folks to have them over
I'm gonna go first they can come to my
house and I'm not cleaning up for you
and they need to bring a side dish
and you're gonna you're gonna provide
the stakes in the grill they can bring
beers they can bring
dessert whatever it is
and I want you to stay on the line I'm
going to send you a whole bunch of packs
of questions for humans so you'll have
something to do yeah instead of just
staring at each other okay that's gonna
be my gift to you
but you got to commit to practicing and
trying it and here's what I promise is
going to happen
a bunch of times guys aren't going to
show up
several times they're going to show up
and it's going to be super weird because
y'all going to realize you vote for
different people and you're going to get
mad
but there'll be one or two or three of
the guys that you really sync with
y'all end up going fishing one one
Sunday afternoon
one of those guys bails you out when you
get sick and they cut your Lawns for you
and you cut them in on the deal
and you're going to realize those that's
my guy
those are my guys
and you're gonna be those guys for them
you see what I'm saying
yeah
it's changing your identity to I'm a guy
that is worth hanging around and it's
about being extra intentional I wish
there with all my heart man I wish there
was a hack to this one
I wish there was some secret like like
hidden algorithm for making friends
there's not you just gotta go risk it
he's got to go risk risk risk risk and
understand that if you just go home from
work every day to your lonely apartment
crack open a beer turn on the TV and
hang out with Ted lasso and all the cast
of the office instead of hanging out
with real people your life is going to
be shorter than other people and more
importantly it's going to be less rich
and less engaged and less joyful
it's not going to be a whole life
and it's not a matter of if it's a
matter of when the storms come you will
need other people other people are your
emergency fund for life you will need
them standing by your side
so I say this from the bottom of my
heart Jeff
you're worth being friends with
go make friends
go be weird risk it all and if they
can't show up or they don't like you
that's on them has nothing to do with
you go on to the next and go on to the
next and go on to the next
you are worth having friends
hang on the line here we'll hook you up
we'll be right back
good folks slowing down is a critical
aspect of mental health calming music
prayers meditation they're all great
ways to find peace and hallow makes it
easy to start a daily practice of
meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling Hollow makes it
easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hallow.com deloney today to get three
months of hollow for free
hallow.com deloney
all right we're back Jack let's go to
Denver Colorado and talk to Dear Marie
what's up Marie
hi Dr John how are you partying um
that's not true yeah yeah what's up
so
I lost my husband about a year ago and
oh God hold on hold on hold on what
happened
uh PTSD
you die by Suicide
yeah
ah God I'm so sorry Marie
thank you
um Hold On Shut your breath take a
breath take a breath take a breath take
a big big deep breath
don't blow by it I'm sorry
thank you
uh shortly after I lost him
um
my best friend and her family were in a
severe car accident and it looked like
they weren't going to survive
and
their whole family survived and they're
all relatively back to normal life right
now
um and I find myself
really angry and jealous that
their family is intact and mine is not
and how do I move forward with that
friendship
um am I a monster for having these
feelings
it's a lot
to answer the the question underneath
the question underneath the question
here you're not crazy
you're not a monster
no
your anger and your jealousy and your
frustration
and
heartbreak that's all good and right
or to be a nerd about it it's totally
normal
I'm sorry
thank you how do I move forward
you're like okay that was cute what do I
do now
sorry
what was what was your husband's name
Neil tell me about him
um he was a veteran
veteran probably the smartest guy I've
ever met in my life
um
he was really
an amazing husband and father and
he was somebody that we always joked
with everybody's buddy you never
ever met an enemy
and he was carrying around a suitcase
full of full of Darkness huh
uh evidently
did he leave you a note
he did
say much didn't say much
oh
um just that
he was sorry and that he he loved me and
trusted me to do what was best for our
kids
and uh
that he hoped we would see each other
again someday
you know that's not your fault Marie
right
I know
and I know that you've spent every day
of the last year asking yourself what if
I just said this what if I had done this
what if I hadn't done that
so hear me say this one's not on you
he's damn lucky to have you in his life
thanks
foreign
so the path out
is the path I was just I was just trying
to to mirror for you okay or just trying
to give you a picture of what it looks
like
and it's slow and it's short and it's
awful
something you have to practice okay and
the reason I'm telling you that is I
don't lie to you because I don't want to
get off the phone and you think balloons
are going to fall from the sky because
that's not how it works
sure okay what's gonna happen is my one
of my greatest friends in the world his
name is Trevor and Trevor
um was working at a print shop and he
tore his bicep he's a big muscle head
he's like the hottest guy in the world
and he was Beefcake and and he tore his
bicep and it rolled up on his shoulder
and he got it surgically repaired and he
had to do all of this PT work all this
uh physical therapy
and he said it was brutal and it was
hard and it hurt all the time and then
after a while he ran out of PT because
his insurance quit paying so he just
went back to his regular life and he
kind of favored it and favored it and
favored it and one day a box fell off
at the print shop and he reached up and
grabbed the Box just just reflexively
and he remembers going huh that didn't
hurt like that's he was well
and so that's what's going to happen
if you'll do these things I'm going to
tell you what's going to happen is
you're going to just have an experience
in six or nine months
when you are going to be overwhelmed
with gratitude and laughter and joy
and it will hit you on the way home
oh wait a minute
you see what I'm saying
yeah that's what's going to happen
there's not going to be glitter or
anything falling from the ceiling okay
you spent the last year in a black hole
and if I'm being really truthful with
you you're going to be there probably
for a little bit longer okay
it's hard yeah you got little ones too
yeah
um
my oldest is two and a half and he died
when I was three months pregnant and so
the baby is five months
boys or girls
girls
so this will be hard for a long long
time okay
okay
as part of your
part of the story that's going to be
your life is letting these little girls
know that Daddy was sick and that he
loved them more than life itself and you
get a note that proves it
yeah okay
so number one you've got to know you're
not nuts you're not crazy when you get
mad when you get angry and when you see
a dad holding his daughter holding his
other daughter's hand walking in the
mall and you just want to go punch him
in the mouth that feeling is right it's
okay
you're not crazy
don't go hit him because then you'll go
to jail but I want you to not be like oh
my gosh what's wrong with me I'm the
worst I can't no go yeah yeah that sucks
and then you've spent the last year
really pissed off
that he left you hanging right
yeah
that that anger is right too
but when you're able to I want you to
begin to also plus the anger not the
anger goes away plus the anger
remember how
he lit up a room
and remember the joy he brought to other
people
and remember how he made you feel when
you were down that one time
what we're doing is we are slowly but
surely turning our dial
to one of
Darkness to one of light
it's one of gratitude to use a word that
has been beaten to death in the
Instagram world
and what we're going to do with your
friend is it's literally practicing
we're gonna practice honoring that
family
practice by writing him a letter about
how happy you are for them and never
give it to them just practice writing
them
and say the words in that letter because
no one's ever going to read it I'm so
freaking pissed off that
my life like my family got busted up
and yours gets to remain whole
I'm so grateful y'all are whole
see what I'm saying all we're doing is
practicing when you're around them
and you feel sorrow and you feel your
chest get tight
that's all okay but I want you to
practice feeling it not just getting so
righteously indignant and angry that you
wallpaper over it
okay
You're Gonna Miss Neil for a long long
time
and that's ultimately what that anger is
so I miss my guy
like my forever guy I miss him
yeah
right
yeah I you're absolutely right
you also need to find a friend or two
that you can say these things out loud
to because you can't do this by yourself
grief Demands a witness
so you're gonna have to find one or two
women that you can text that you really
trust with your soul
or that you can call and say I'm going
to visit so and so and her stupid
freaking perfect husband with still has
all his hair and didn't cover himself up
in tattoos and doesn't have a jacked up
Jeep out in the
he's gonna be there too
and they need to be able to go boo with
you on your side right
yeah and then you can walk in and your
chest is going to get tight and you're
going to see this guy is going to smile
and say Welcome to our house and your
friend's gonna be your girlfriend's
gonna be there and your daughters are
going to run in the house and you're
going to feel it for a second
damn it Neil you should be here too
[Music]
and then we're gonna walk in and we're
gonna smile and we're going to choose
gratitude
not choose faking we're going to choose
gratitude look how beautiful this house
is look how beautiful this marriage is
and what you'll find is if you commit to
practicing this over time in addition to
feeling your anger feeling so mad
and by the way this anger will come in
waves this grief comes in waves it's
going to be four years old when your
daughter hears something from somebody
at school and comes home
and wants to have another conversation
about her daddy
God you're gonna get pissed again so you
have to have this conversation you gotta
tell her you know you know what I mean
this is going to be part of your story
those are all okay they're all okay
if nothing else you hear me say you're
not screwed up you're not messed up
you're not irredeemable you're not a
monster
you're a mom who loves her two baby
girls and you're a wife who is
heartbroken because you lost your
Forever guy
mm-hmm
have you written him a letter yet
I told him you hate him
uh no nothing so formal as writing a
letter you gotta do that
I always tell people to write three
letters
you got to tell them to write him the
letter
about
how mad you are upset you are how
frustrated and angry you are
you gotta write him a letter that tells
him how sad you are
then you got to write him a letter that
it's going to let him know who you're
going to become in the coming years
what he's gonna miss
because Marie is going to be the best
single mom the world has ever seen
and she's going to make many of this
madness and you're going to
not forget the the forget the name Neil
because Neil Neil is all right he was
just sick
yeah but those three letters are
important because it takes what's in
that in your body and puts it out into
the ether
and also gives your body permission to
be angry and really sad and optimistic
all at the same time
when you can will you commit to that
I will yeah
and then the fourth letter is that
pretend the letter God help you don't
send it please don't send it to your
friends
we're good friends but I don't know that
we're that good
I hey
I have an un as my wife says uh
I'm awkward in what conversations I will
just have at the dinner table with our
friends because I thought every friend
group did that but evidently they do not
but I even would be weirded out if
someone's like man
I really just being around you really
um pisses me off and makes me mad like I
would be like I don't know what to do
um so yeah maybe a counselor but you
might be a good person or some other
friends but
um
what we're gonna do over the next one to
two to five to six to ten years is
slowly turn that dial from one of black
hole to one of gratitude
and when you see a whole family it
becomes something that you quietly pump
your fist and you say hell yeah
when you see a broken family or a family
experiencing loss it's you're going to
be lying to them because you're going to
have been there and you're going to be
able to look somebody in the eye and put
your hand on both sides of their face
and say I know you call me anytime
but that's not for now right now it's
still here no that's for healing right
now
so start with writing um new letters all
three of them
and listen to me I'll be with you all
through this you holler anytime I can
help walk alongside me I mean I'm
walking alongside you any way I can help
and I want you to hang on the line I'm
gonna send you a copy of on your past
change your future
um just it's a measly gift I can give to
you it's all I got
um actually I'm gonna send you the
parents and kids cars it'll be something
fun for you and your daughters to play
with it's the questions even though I
guess you told me they're really really
young so you may put them in a drawer
for a few years
um but I want you to read on your past
change your future as
just here we are
this is what grief feels like this is
what grief looks like and then what are
we gonna do next
I'm so grateful for you I'm heartbroken
with you
we're all heartbroken with you Marie
we'll be with you with next steps
thank you so much for being brave thank
you for the call we'll be right back
[Music]
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible in each person's situation is
unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well-life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
so a few months ago Kelly showed up to
work and she I mean it was pretty
gangster she had shaved her head except
for like long bangs like skaters did
back in the 80s like old Tony Hawk it
looked really dope now she's got this
wig thing I don't know what she's doing
but she had shaved her head completely
and on the back of her head
it was this intense tattoo at first I
thought it was like a planet it wasn't
it was a huge bug
and if you like you to look on top and
like kind of look over her
um and she yeah it's a whole thing
um usually she's sitting at her desk and
asking people to like fan her and things
like that so there's people always
lording over her all the time just as a
part of her Dominion but she has this
big tattoo on the back of her it's like
the size of my palm and it's a bug
ger this one up and I know you got a lot
of grief for shaving your head but it
was dope when you did it but listen
it was a beetle I didn't realize that
the Beatles are one of her favorite
bands in the world and it was really rad
and it looks cool and I'll give you this
I'm not a Beatles fan I've tried to
become and I just I can't hang I can't
hang
but good for you for being the world's
biggest beetles fan
at 200 head that's incredible song's
called
With a Little Help from My Friends and
it goes like this
what would you think if I Sing Out Of
Tune
would you stand up and walk out on me
lend me your ears and I'll sing you a
song and I'll try not to sing out a key
I give Bob a Little Help from My Friends
and Kelly gets high With a Little Help
from her friends
I'm gonna try With a Little Help from My
Friends what do I do when my love is
away does it worry you to be alone how
do I feel by the end of the day are you
sad because you're on your own now I get
Bob a Little Help from My Friends
Kelly gets really high with her friends
I'm gonna try With a Little Help from My
Friends everybody
go make friends cherish them
cherish them we'll see you soon
foreign